[Musique]
pour en débattre nous sommes avec yves
contassot membres de génération s ex
europe ecologie les verts ancien adjoint
au maire de paris bonsoir il veut
contrer son merci d'être avec nous avons
couché bonsoir jacques myard mer et
l'air de maisons laffitte dans les
yvelines bonsoir à vous jacques milliard
alors les verts qui favorise des
islamistes
quelle est votre réaction jacques myard
roudier c'est assez simple en réalité
vous avez un certain nombre je dirais de
mouvement politique qui essaie de
ramener à eux avec une idéologie un
certain nombre de minorités et qui est
temps de la main on l'a vu notamment
rêver socialistes qui ont voulu
magnifique et les émigrés puisque les
ouvriers n'étaient plus avec le parti
socialiste et donc il ya une volonté de
conquérir des votes
il y à aussi en parallèle je pense que
je pense à sauvera pas dire le contraire
une volonté de la part des mouvements
des verts de briser un certain nombre de
tabous il faut le lire pour le dire et
de se présenter et comme des novateurs
politique
je ne leur conteste pas parce que avec
les verts je ne suis pas en total
désaccord avec eux lorsqu'ils disent qui
est produite et compte les plastiques
qu'ils ont parfaitement raison en
revanche j'ai beaucoup d'autres je
dirais vision différente qu'ils peuvent
professé d'un certain côté vous ne
jamais oublier qu'ils ont une tradition
qui vient aussi de moments trotskiste et
est donc ça reste de ce mais c'est pas
la peine de dire vous n'êtes pas
d'accord il faut pas nier les évidences
mon cher collègue
non mais un peu d'histoire monsieur
myard l'origine du mouvement écolo
rien aucun 36,2 dans aucun verts à
l'extérieur et rouges à l'intérieur
savez vous dire bleus à l'extérieur et
brun l'intérieur pour ce qui vous
concerne le plan complètement camarades
bon il est démis d'or je vous permets
pas de m'appeler camarades et de tutoyer
on n'est pas copain s'attaquer aussi un
élément
deuxième élément c'est pas en affirmant
de manière péremptoire des énormités que
vous arriverez à la nef les voûtes
racisme naples est allaité politique et
que aujourd'hui on demande à un certain
nombre de moments des verts qui vont
chercher des voix et qui se confirme là
alors l'islamo gauchisme c'est par kim
sourit sa maman gauchistes c'est qu'en
réalité il y a une démarche politique
qui est d'aller à la rencontre d'un
certain nombre de minorités qui sont pas
toujours fréquentable et qui s'essaye de
ramener eux c'est ça la réalité et donc
contassot a tout de même
marlène schiappa qui rajoute un yves
contassot les verts flamands depuis de
plus en plus dangereusement avec des
thèses islamistes
c'est vrai que ça va mal et n'y a pas et
coutumières de dérapages c'est pas le
premier est d'ailleurs en marche et
globalement coutumier dérapages vous
rappellerai simplement les propos
antisémites de monsieur darmana dans son
dernier ouvrage le corps être pu signer
paraît-il madame le pen donc on voit
bien qu une espèce de course à
l'échalote entre en marche et le rn pour
savoir lequel des deux va utiliser
l'autre pour rester en face à face au 2e
tour au détriment évidemment d'un débat
intelligent on est dans la caricature la
plus absolue
c'est totalement stupide la meilleure
preuve c'est que l'ancien maire de
strasbourg et l'ancien préfet le préfet
avait posé la première pierre est la
personne n'avait
à j personne n'avait rien dit personne y
compris monsieur d'armements y compris y
compris le président n'a lui qui prétend
maintenant qu'il a des informations
confidentielles sur la volonté de l'état
turc ne intervenir dans les débats mais
qu'ils le disent qu'ils donnent mal des
offres de tout ça on est dans la
fabrication dans la manipulation
politicienne de la droite de l'extrême
croire au détriment de l'apaisement de
la société est derrière tout ça qu'est
ce qui se cache dans l'oralité
c'est du racisme ne veut pas s'assumer
qu'il veut pas osé dire ce qu'il est
la réponse de jacques myard du racisme
était ce n'est pas le dire est de faire
du révisionnisme historique parce que
dans cette affaire qui est d'une
solution restante qu'il vous plaît
monsieur compte astro et voulait faire
l'émission tout seul libre à vous mais
laissait aussi et ça c'est pas le droit
de leur production quelle qu'elle soit
de s'exprimer or vous ne pratiquez pas
de guerre le terrorisme intellectuel
vous êtes capable de s'appliquer à
longueur de temps est bon ce titre man à
thème c'est votre salon j'ai pensé alors
contassot écoute ça lui permettra
justement de comprendre combien il est
dans l'erreur ce qui se passe sur cette
histoire de mosquées c'est que qu'il y
ait bien sûr un lieu de culte pour les
musulmans personne va le contester
mais ce qui est nouveau c'est que tout
d'un coup on vous annonce ce qu'il n'y a
pas une très forte subvention et que
cette subvention est donnée à des gens
qui nient les principes de la république
donc il ya quand même des limites où les
communes par la subvention vous savez
que c'est légal dans la loi du concordat
en alsace maintenant effectivement sur
les valeurs de la république c'est autre
chose fait d'autres choix sont sauf si
vous voulez bien que la décision de
construire cette mosquée n'a pas été
prise par la maire actuelle de
strasbourg où elle a été prise il y a
plusieurs années par l'ancienne équipe
avec la bénédiction de l'est
état du préfet du gouvernement qui était
sous la responsabilité de monsieur
darmana et de monsieur macro qui ni l'un
ni l'autre n'ont trouvé à l'époque que
cette association nous poser problème et
comme ça on est une élue écolo non ce
qui est gros c'est votre négation de la
réalité et ça c'est un négationniste
puisque bien on renaît on vous connaît
il suffit de regarder autour on va faire
lancer le débat on va écouter xavier
thibault docteur en droit public a sa
petite idée sur la question et coûté 2
avant de vous faire réagir pour europe
ecologie les verts il a des dominants et
des dominés et parmi ces dominé il ya
les islamistes l'islam politique
il y à l'islam radical parce que par
principe il serait dominée par principe
on ne peut pas les attaquer
par principe on ne peut pas s'en prendre
à eux par principe on doit même leur
faire une discrimination positive
on doit les finances et les aider dans
tous les sens c'est un dogme tellement
installé chez europe ecologie les verts
qu'en réalité ils ne réfléchissent plus
aux enjeux géopolitiques votre réponse
ou votre défensif contassot prétend est
un spécialiste affirmé avec une telle
force des mensonges extraordinaire je le
mets au défi au défi de sortir un texte
une intervention un communiqué qu'ils
pourraient appuyer ses propos je le mets
au défi ah bon
wifi seule fois un texte il prise de
position publique d'europe écologie les
verts des écologistes en général qu'ils
défendraient l'islamisme radical comme
image
enfin c'est pas sérieux
sionisme et le négationnisme on est en
plein dedans
vous avez une démarche qui avait parlé à
tort et à travers
tu avais raison ce qui est en jeu
aujourd'hui hélas cette analyse est vrai
c'est qu'il ya une démarche d'aller à
l'égard 2
quand on dit qu'ils sont des victimes
est bon qu'on va les aider
c'est ce qu'on a vu déjà au parti
socialiste avec terra nova où ils ont
voulu je dirais courtiser les émigrés
parce qu'ils n'avaient plus d'ouvriers
au parti socialiste
vous êtes dans la même démarche de logis
et que vous le niez de cette manière
sans apporter un moment de preuve
contraire de ce qui vient de là ça
prouve la faiblesse de vos arguments sa
bouche de vos abattis ne porte pas la
preuve du contraire justement servi
donnez moi messieurs dont il sémitisme
ya une autre résolution qui crée des
polémiques un toujours au même endroit à
strasbourg en alsace une résolution
municipal contre l'antisémitisme qui a
été rejetée selon quotidien l'alsace
elle visait à définir le plus
précisément possible aux skis et
antisémites et avait déjà été retoqué en
en février de nouveau à l'ordre du jour
elle n'a pas été adoptée je vous propose
d'écouter cette fois ci la réaction de
la ministre du logement
voici la résolution que le groupe europe
ecologie les verts au conseil municipal
de strasbourg a choisi de rejeter quelle
motivation derrière cet abandon de la
lutte contre l'antisémitisme sous toutes
ses formes
à mesure que les dykes saute les masques
tombent
ça voudrait dire y feront tassant qu'il
ya deux poids deux mesures vous vous
réfutez eux ce doute
j'observe simplement que la ministre dit
voilà la nahb la résolution qui a été
rejetée même ne la lis pas et je
rappelle qu'il ya une définition
juridique de l'antisémitisme
l'antisémitisme comme toute forme de
racisme est un délit
donc soit on s'en tient aux textes
juridiques
soit on essaye de tordre la loi avec
évidemment là encore l'idée d'une ou de
la manipulation comme dans la sphère de
la mosquée pour des raisons
électoralistes
aujourd'hui on le voit bien monsieur
macro veut rester le seul en face de
madame le pen et il a vu depuis des mois
en france comme ailleurs que l'écologie
devient une alternative à l'extrême
droite
et ça il en a très peur et donc qui va
pas
son temps à taper sur les écolos pour
essayer d affaiblir pour être ce faisant
il fait le match pied à madame le pen la
victime contassot
bien sûr les seniors c'est la ligne de
deux porte parole de la force parole
d'écologie ne pardonnez moi une
polémique et nous dit eva sas à une
polémique créée de toutes pièces par
sherpa et darmanin peut-être parce qu'il
est accusé de propos antisémites dans
son livre peut-être que c'est un
contre-feu qu'il ait said à lui mais c
est la vie en tout cas d'europe écologie
les verts jacques myard je suis un
opposant à ce gouvernement et je suis
aliments convaincu que ce que paient
effectivement les maquereaux nice
essayer d'avoir le même duo dans 1910 en
2017 c'est voué à l'échec
là je rejoindrai amicaux face aux amis
camarades
mais ce qui est certain c'est que on ne
la question de l'antisémitisme
je ne vais pas accuser monsieur patate
chaude et antisémites ça c'est évident
mais ce qui est certain est que je
constate aujourd'hui en donne un coup de
main à des gens qui sont directement
liés à air de gamme et là j'ai vu ce que
d existence
c'est absolument inadmissible d ailleurs
si vous invite à lire le nombre
d'articles et actes
nous avons publié génération comme les
six colloques aux fournisseurs des
vagues ce qu'il fait partie de
considérer ou ailleurs nous sommes
habités ne met pas d'une api a lancé et
qui a financé monsieur erdogan pour
qu'ils règlent les problèmes de
l'immigration en europe
essilor est cotée moi bien je ne suis
pas écolo erdogan essaye de manipuler un
certain nombre d'associations assez pour
peser sur la politique nationale tant en
allemagne qu'en france
et ça je ne peux pas l'accepter or vous
vous faites les pompistes erdogan
c'est ça la réalité il n'ya pas bien on
n'en est pas là hier politique alors que
présente comme si de rien à faire
les trois responsables qui ont à paris
il y est ils n'ont évidemment mais c'est
bien pour ça que je fais et pardonnez
moi pour avancer dans les bas côtés
somme c'est vrai que les verts sont pas
à leur première polémique ans a fait
souvent parler septembre 2020 j'en cite
un bordeaux qui célèbre un arbre mort
lyon le maire dénonce le tour de france
comme polluant et mathis toujours lyon
février menus sans viande temporaire ça
avait créé le débat je prends bordeaux
tenait quand on voit une ville
traditionnellement plutôt à droite à la
ville d'alain juppé qui vote écolo est
ce qu'on se dise que ses habitants sont
vraiment en face justement avec la
proche sur la les questions de laïcité
notamment plus proche il faut bien le
dire que la france a soumis ce que que
de l air est ce que quand on vote écolo
en gros parce qu'on est pour l'écologie
on s'attend peut-être avoir ce type
d'idées qui sont effectivement plus
proche de la france insoumise c'est une
question mais ça c'est une affirmation
gratuite sur un certain nombre de
questions il a sauvé sa vie
jean luc mélenchon comme jean luc
mélenchon a été entouré par d'un certain
nombre de personnes dont il s'est séparé
fort heureusement d'ailleurs qui sont
partis plus tôt de la france insoumise
nous avons dénoncé les propos qui ont
été tenus
nous les avons dénoncé et sans hésiter
parce que précisément qu'on nous la
laïcité ça a du sens et nous voulons
c'est pas nous qui demandons le
changement de la loi de 1905 nous
noterons qu'elle est très bien cette loi
et qu'il n'y a rien à échanger rien
strictement rien en revanche ce que nous
voulons c'est l'égalité de l'ensemble
des religions l'ensemble des religions
quelles qu'elles soient alors dès lors
qu'elles respectent effectivement
l'esprit et la lettre de la vague
récente sur le côté radical peut-être
des dévers
cette race blanche justement l époque
qu'elle perd vous savez lorsque vous
adresser à un verre il vous donne une
version quand vous allez c'est un autre
il nous en donne une autre mais quand il
était bondé pour les chats je parle en
mon nom personnel et je peux vous dire
que j'ai toujours été cohérent avec tout
les la laïcité est effectivement un
socle de la république et je m'étonne
effectivement du côté des verts on la
biolle au pied merci à mon parti si on
la respecte au contraire et on l'a dit
en outre pour l'un défend non non non
non mais dites moi monsieur myard si
vous êtes pour la défense de la laïcité
stricte et le respect de la loi de 1905
que pensez vous du fait que l'ensemble
des religions sur l'ensemble du
territoire français soit financée par
l'état sur l'ensemble du territoire
français
vous avez lumière sur la lumière mais
enfin vous connaissez la loire sont les
deux ans voici donc la sensation à
tergnier pour finir belgique lorraine et
qui a été sanctionné par le français qu
il savait le lien que si vous donnez
[Musique]
d'autres disent qu'elle s'est pas le
problème c'est ça le problème c'est
qu'elle erdogan
c'est pas des religions merci merci
contassot et mercia ja lumière en tout
cas d'avoir accepté ce face à la voilà
on vous mettra pas d'accord ce soir
merci à vous en tout cas merci c'est ça
une butte d'un face à face en tout cas
merci à vous tous et bonne soirée